hi my name is Adrian Ludwig I'm on the
Android security team here at Google and
just this week we released our 2016 Year
in Review
and so I know that it's a long document
and a lot of folks won't have the
opportunity to go through the entire
thing so we wanted to put together a few
of the highlights talk through them and
give you a little bit of perspective on
what we've seen over the last year in
Android security so to begin with what's
incredible is the continued growth in
the Android ecosystem and along with the
growth in the Android ecosystem our
protections have grown as well in 2016
we grew to protect over 1.4 billion
devices out in the ecosystem across the
entire globe we scan over 750 million
devices per day so an incredibly large
investment in checking what's going on
in the ecosystem and understanding both
the protections that we have in place
but also the risks that users are being
exposed to one of the most important
characteristics of the Android ecosystem
is how we've committed to being open and
from a security standpoint that's
incredibly valuable it gives us the
ability to tap into the collective
intelligence around the world that's
invested in protecting the Android
ecosystem users devices and applications
so you don't have to rely just on Google
just on OMS are just on carriers you can
rely really on the entire world and its
commitment to protecting itself and
that's something that's unique about the
way we've designed our ecosystem is the
ability to bring in that collective
intelligence to facilitate that
intelligence and make sure that the best
things are being done it's really
important that there be data that there
be transparency into what's happening in
the ecosystem the direction and the
types of threats that users being
exposed to so this year in review report
is just one example of the type of
transparency that we're trying to
provide and make sure it's pervasive
across the entire ecosystem openness
also means choice it means that you can
look at the data understand what's going
on in the ecosystem and make decisions
about how you interact with your device
about what type of device you select
about where you install applications
from so all of this is designed to make
it possible for users to do the right
thing for themselves as they're
interacting with the rest of the world
through the Android ecosystem
the reflection of that is the incredible
types of experiences that were being
built and these are experiences that
depend at their core on the security of
their devices things as simple as games
where the integrity of the operating
system is critical to the functioning of
gameplay things like ride-sharing or
other sort of social mechanisms for
consummating transactions uber lyft and
all of the other types of applications
that have been built on top of the
Android platform and other mobile
platforms depend upon the security of
those environments some of the most
exciting examples of how we're seeing
Android and mobile devices transform how
people interact with the world are at
the high end right where payments are
becoming easier and easier on mobile
devices because of the integrity and
security of these operating systems and
even at the very extreme high end you
see users who are potentially some of
the most significant targets in the
world right
state leaders national leaders
international leaders who are able to
use the openness and flexibility of
Android to build very secure
capabilities that haven't been possible
on closed systems in the past for me
personally one of the things that's most
exciting is that Android has facilitated
low-end devices being more secure so for
users who aren't able to commit hundreds
of dollars or even thousands of dollars
to protect themselves they still get
out-of-the-box protection and that's one
of the things that I'm personally very
committed to and the team around me and
Google are very committed to as well
making sure that everybody in the world
our billions of users have access to the
best security protections that are
available so they can go about their
lives in knowing and having confidence
in their mobile device so that's sort of
how we approach it from a strategic
standpoint when we look at a single year
we begin to see what the trend lines
look like and so I wanted to hit a few
of the highlights that are included in
the annual report it's about 75 pages
long so you may not have an opportunity
to read the entire thing but here are
some of the takeaways that you can
probably hang on to and think about over
the coming year the first is the
expansion of the protections that we
have that are service based in the
ecosystem so actively checking and
improving the consumer developer
Enterprise protections to make sure that
users have the best in
impossible so a big investment in those
kinds of capabilities we've also
invested quite a bit in the platform
security when I talk about the platform
I mean the open source technology that's
delivered on all Android devices so
we've enhanced it with key security
technologies greater adoption of
encryption greater adoption of smart
lock we'll talk through some of the
trends that we've seen over the last
year as we go through more of the
content one of the most significant
changes in 2016 was that we transitioned
towards having monthly security update
including security fixes that have been
found by the security community outside
of the Google as well as our researchers
here in Google we had 12 security
updates on a monthly basis and we're
going to continue that going into 2017 a
very significant adoption of those by
OEMs across the entire Android ecosystem
one of the hallmarks of our Year in
Review is a focus on data and looking at
what's actually happening in the
ecosystem and so there are a few
measurements that we're gonna call out
and I'll sort of walk through them as we
go through this presentation but they go
really into deep great detail in in the
written out form of the annual report
some of those data are around malware
and the distribution of malware 2016
relatively flat very slight declines in
the overall number of devices that have
malware installed from what we saw in
2015 on a category by category basis
whether devices were in play or outside
of play we saw those declines and one of
the highlights for me was that 50 out of
the top 50 most most populous countries
in terms of number of devices that they
have that are downloading applications
saw a decline in the rates of malware
getting onto those devices so incredible
progress that we've made in protecting
Android users across the Android
ecosystem and then since there was a lot
of news about Android security as to
spend the case for the last several
years we'll flag a couple of the most
prominent stories and talk through where
those stories went after they hit their
peak in the headlines and then how they
declined throughout the year as
protections have kicked into place and
made sure that users ended up in a safe
place so we're gonna walk through three
different primary areas the robust
platform services and updates and talk
through the changes that happen in 2016
so here we go
let's take a look at the platform
at this point Android has delivered on
most of the major security capabilities
that are expected of any mobile platform
we have strong integrity through
verified boot going up through the
entire stack it's tied to a hardware
root of trust encryption has been
enabled for two major releases and so
we've begun to see substantial adoption
of a krip ssin across the Android
ecosystem so there are a number of
significant features that were delivered
in 2016 but one of the most important
characteristics of these features was
not the technology itself but the rate
at which it was being picked up and the
rate at which were able to deliver new
security technology into the platform so
this is a graph that's included in the
report it talks about the fact that even
though encryption of full disk
encryption was enabled all the way
almost four or five years ago in the
Android platform prior to android 5.1
there was practically no adoption of it
it was there users just didn't turn it
on and so we saw adoption that was less
than 1% it became required for new
devices with Android 6 oh and with
Android 7 oh we saw continued
acceleration so we went from 1% to 20 to
80% and we're expecting that that will
continue to grow until we achieve over
the next couple of years nearly 100%
adoption of encryption across the
Android ecosystem so that I think is one
of the most important stories of 2016 in
terms of features is recognizing that
these features are able to achieve
velocity and adoption very very quickly
which is really exciting here's another
feature this one there were changes in
how users interact with the feature but
not as substantial as one encryption so
we saw adoption of smart lock go up by
over 175 percent so the story here is
really understanding that the features
that are being released are being picked
up and being used very very quickly and
so when we look at the core platform
capabilities the fact that all of the
major features are in place and we're
now starting to enter a phase of
incrementalism in terms of the features
that are being introduced into Android I
think we're actually in a really
exciting place for getting these
features out to as many users as
possible it also makes it possible for
us to focus on the details really invest
in individual security researchers
expanding the number of people who are
finding issues and reporting on them so
one of the areas that we've been
investing a lot in 2016 is in our
security rewards program the way this
program works is anybody in the world
can become a security researcher focused
on Android all they have to do is find
issues and report them to us one of the
really fascinating characteristics that
we've seen of the security rewards
program is who it is that it draws in
areas of the world that previously have
not been significantly involved in
providing independent security research
have really flourished on the Android so
areas of China Eastern Europe and a
number of other places around the world
that previously hadn't had a significant
amount of public open security research
have really been contributing a lot to
Android to the tune of over a hundred
different contributors around the world
and over a million dollars invested in
finding and fixing security issues on
the Android platform so that's where
we've been investing in the platform
itself the other area that we've been
investing is in comprehensive services
these are the services that we use to
help monitor the ecosystem and react in
near real-time to issues that might be
found so let's talk through some of
those capabilities as you may recall
from last year's Year in Review or if
you've been looking closely at what
we're doing in Android security there's
four different areas that we're
investing in services the first is
around analyzing applications I'll talk
more about that just a second we call
that verify apps the second is what we
refer to as the sensor network or
sometimes we talk about it as safety net
this is looking at non application based
signals on a device to try to find
potential security risks so we're
analyzing whether devices might be being
exploited in the browser whether they
might be running into network problems
or any other type of issue that has
security significance the third thing
that we invest in is protections for
lost or stolen devices it continues to
be the case that the largest threat that
most users face is a potential loss of
the device where not only is their data
exposed to risk but they also are
potentially losing the significant
financial investment that they've made
and what may be one of their most
important and valued possessions and so
the Android device manager is designed
to help users lock or find a stolen or
lost device the fourth area that's a
pillar for our our
services as AP is recognizing that
Google has built these services made
them available to consumers but that
there are application developers that
might want to take advantage of them as
well and so API is an area that we've
invested in significantly and the report
goes into a number of different examples
of the types of API so I'll talk about
just one today the application review
process continues to be one of the most
high-profile and significant services
that we have available within Google
services for Android it plays two
different functions the first function
is to make sure that any application
that gets uploaded to Google Play has
gone through a comprehensive security
review that means dynamic analysis
looking at signatures third-party
reports having a integrated approach to
handling security reports from other
security solution providers antivirus
companies etc it also means that we pull
in data from the safety net sensor
network to see what's actually happening
out on the ecosystem so that we can
actually incorporate that into assessing
whether an application is safe to be on
Google Play so that's one function that
we play the other is to provide a
protection for applications being
installed outside of Google Play and
they go through exactly the same level
of scrutiny so very very detailed
scrutiny that in many cases can be fully
automated but in some cases ends up
going to a final manual human review so
we can categorize applications into one
of about 20 different categories of
potentially harmful application or say
that it's safe and the user can go on
and install and go about their business
we constantly review these applications
to see if there's anything that's
changed if there's no data that's
available or even if maybe we made a
mistake in the past because these things
happen when you're operating at the type
of scale that we're operating at with
over 6 billion applications reviewed
every single day so we've got a little
video that sort of takes you through the
process to understand how it is that we
approach it and we'll play it here and
take a look at it did you know Android
has built-in antivirus protection that
gets more powerful every second it
starts when an Android developer uploads
their app to Google Play
a self-learning at risk analyzer scans
and simulates apps looking for potential
security issues if there's an issue the
app won't appear in Google Play on
Android devices verify apps regularly
scans for harmful behavior warning users
and then sending this information to the
analyzer so it keeps getting smarter
safety net also scans devices for
exploits and Network vulnerabilities
protecting more than 1 billion devices
daily and again sending data back for
the analyzer to get more powerful
Android and Google Play constantly
making your mobile device safer at home
or and everywhere in between one of the
areas that we've significantly increased
our investment in 2016 was in what's
called machine learning neural networks
and providing artificial intelligence as
a means to detect harmful behavior one
of the most interesting characteristics
that we found as we begin to develop
these new technologies is that often
discovery is not about looking for the
needle in the haystack it's about trying
to find the effect of that needle or
trying to see what impact it has so one
of the approaches that's represented
here visually is where we cluster
applications together so we're not
necessarily looking for the specific bad
behavior within these clusters but we
identify applications that are related
based on some characteristics right all
applications that abuse SMS all
applications that take advantage of the
users fish the users credentials what's
called phishing these clusters get
created and then in an automated fashion
we can detect applications that look
similar to the other members of a
cluster but that haven't been
categorized and that accelerates our
ability to identify potential related
applications that wouldn't be visible to
a human right there are just too many
variables that are in there so we're
looking at literally hundreds of
thousands of different characteristics
of any one application and then trying
to see how it might be related to
millions of other applications that are
out there in the ecosystem the human
brain just can't process that sort of
scale and so we're using machine
learning and neural networks to build
out these kinds of cake
another investment we've made that's at
incredible scale is a technology called
Safe Browsing originally developed at
Google almost 10 years ago this is a
protection that's been built into most
of the world's major browsers at this
point on most of the world's major
platforms so Windows iOS and on Android
and what it does is it warns users about
potential risks on a specific website or
HTML based page that they might be going
to on Android we've gone one step
further not only is it exposed as a
capability inside the browser but it's
also an API so any application can
incorporate this technology directly and
protect users in the context of their
application when it might be displaying
web content we've seen of course that
there is some bad behavior out there on
the web and so there are many instances
where we're flagging things across the
ecosystem and helping to protect users
that way another area that we've been
investing in as I mentioned is
identifying bad applications and then
protecting users from that this graph
that I'm showing here right now that's
described in more detail than in the
full annual report is simultaneously one
of the most boring and one of the most
exciting graphs and I think it's it's
boringness that is what's telling for
many years there's been a concern that
at any moment there could be an uptick
in that in the level of potentially
harmful applications that are installed
on Android devices so this graph goes
back almost three years at this point
showing quarter by quarter how many
devices in the Android ecosystem had a
potentially harmful application
installed and what's interesting about
it is how flat it is it's how boring it
is and that speaks to the efforts that
we've had in place to protect users on
an ongoing basis every time we see an
uptick in the line new protections are
introduced every time we see a downtick
new protections are introduced and so
we're able to keep it nice and stable
even though there's a very active
efforts to exploit or take advantage of
Android users as is to be naturally
expected on ecosystem of this scale with
the device the diversity of use cases
that Android is facing
and so really excited that this is
continued to stay stable with about 0.7
percent of Android devices having a
potentially harmful application
installed on them in 2016
we look both at the number of devices
that have a potentially harmful
application installed we also look at
the mechanism by which these
installations take place and so the
second graph here that's described in
more detail in the report provides an
overview of different channels that
users might install from if they're
installing from outside of Google Play
we did see a decrease in the the number
the amount of risk that a user's exposed
to about 9% of installations from
outside of Google Play or potentially
harmful applications in 2015 and 2016
we've cut that nearly in half to about
4.8% in the context of Google Play which
is the lower line here we've also cut it
by about 50% but the baseline was a lot
lower which has gives us the ability to
make a statement that the risks of
installing from Google Play are about
1/10 the risk that a user is exposed to
if they're installing from outside of
Google Play we're going to continue
investing in both of these areas to make
sure that we've have the best possible
protections in Google Play and the best
possible protections for users who are
installing outside of Google Play that's
the commitment that we've made to the
ecosystem to maintain openness but also
allow for users to be safe in the face
of that kind of openness there's a lot
more detail there on the right-hand side
and in the full report I'd encourage you
to go take a look if you want to get
into it there are a number of other
slices of the data that are included in
the annual review one of them is country
by country not going to dive into the
detail here but as I mentioned sort of
the beginning of the presentation of the
50 largest most populous user bases for
Android those countries every one of
them had a decline outside of Google
Play in 2016 and the overall risk that
users were exposed to in installing
applications so very proud of the fact
that we're seeing the ecosystem get
better at protecting itself on a
country-by-country basis we also have in
the side the annual report breakdown on
type of application so enterprises for
example may not be as concerned about
SMS fraud where or maybe they aren't
they're maybe they're very concerned
about Trojans or backdoors or phishing
of user credentials and so we break it
down category by category most of the
major categories did see a decline both
inside of Google Play and on this next
graph outside of Google Play as well so
you can take a look at the report and
get into the full details of where and
what types of risks users or their being
exposed to and understand what it looks
like but to summarize it basically in
2016 everything got a little bit better
which is exciting for a security you
know practitioner to know that the
efforts that we're investing are
actually working and we're seeing users
get to a place that's safer than it was
in 2015 14 and sort of goes on backwards
in time one of the key learnings that
we've had over the last several years is
that just protecting from malware is not
sufficient that there are use cases at
an application level but also at a
personal level where users want to know
more about the environment that their
applications are running and how safe
their environment is one of the things
that was introduced in 2015 is what we
call the safety net access station API
this is an API that's exposed to
application developers whether that be
you know an enterprise inside of their
MDM agent or maybe a banking application
and their direct-to-consumer application
or one of the largest areas of adoption
we've seen is actually in the gaming
space where games which are in some
cases multi-billion dollar businesses on
a annual run rate and have all of their
revenue coming from these client devices
that are running Android iOS and other
mobile operating systems they really
depend upon the integrity of these
devices and so some of them take
advantage of these api's so because
there are over 200 million instances of
the safety net it's a station API being
invoked on a daily basis around the
world we're able to get a good view of
the integrity of devices around the
world and so we go into the annual
report and break that down sort of
country by country here's a
visualization and you can see some
highlights right in Japan over 97% of
devices have an intact security model
that has gone through the Google
certification process so very high
degree of confidence there
it's lesser in some of the other areas
of the world India is an area of the
world for example where the number of
devices that have gone through
certification is significantly lower at
about 86% and that's an area that we're
gonna be making investments in 2017 and
into the future to make sure that we're
able to raise both the quality and the
compatibility of these devices around
the world so that gives you a sense for
the services and the protections that
we've put in place and how those are
playing out in the ecosystem the last
area that I wanted to spend some time
talking about is specifically around
updates this has been a very substantial
area of investment for Google over 2016
as well as for a lot of our partners in
the Android ecosystem so I want to talk
a little bit about what we've been doing
on terms of updating both devices at the
operating system level but also in terms
of updating applications and making it
possible for developers to be responsive
to potential security risks in their
applications so to start let's talk
about devices it's been a really
exciting year 2015 we introduced what
was called the security patch level
which made it possible to track how many
devices were being updated with security
updates in the past it simply wasn't
possible the diversity of devices in the
ecosystem and the diversity of versions
made it very challenging to do that and
there were actually security research
that was done by the University of
Cambridge and a few other places just to
understand how many devices were being
updated so simply being able to
understand was a significant progress in
beyond that once we could see that we
could see that over half of the top 50
devices at the end of 2002 16 had an
available security patch and in fact
over half of the devices in the Android
ecosystem over 700 million devices
received a security update at some point
in 2016 so significant investment across
all of the different OEMs
here we've also highlighted a few of the
devices that are receiving updates very
very quickly
and are maintaining on an ongoing basis
a high level of patching devices coming
from Google like the pixel pixel XL the
Moto Z from Motorola Oppo the AAA 33w
the Nexus 6p Nexus 5 + 5 X + 6
Samsung with the galaxy s7 so
wide range of different devices that are
receiving security updates on a regular
basis so really exciting to see in 2016
the ability to actually understand
what's happening and great progress in
terms of getting devices brought up to
date one of the reason that those
security updates are so important is
because of the active investment that
we're making in security research
earlier I talked about over a hundred
different security researchers worldwide
and over a million dollars spent on
finding security issues and then
resolving those security issues across
the ecosystem the result of that labor
was over 600 different security issues
that were identified and that were
solved through security bulletins that
were delivered on a monthly basis so an
incredible amount of investment diverse
set of perspectives and opinions that
are being brought in that ultimately
make the Android ecosystem that much
more strong I'm so really excited to see
that level of investment being made and
the results that we're getting from
security research program and the
security patches being pushed out to
Android devices we want to make sure
that that same level of scrutiny that's
applied at the operating system level
can be applied at the application level
as well my history and the history of a
lot of folks in the security community
has been to watch investments made at
the platform level never really make it
to the applications and then the
applications become the weakest link and
so with the Android we're trying to make
sure that that doesn't happen by making
early investments in detecting and
preventing security vulnerabilities at
the application level one of the
programs that we've put in place is
what's called the Google Play
application security improvements
program this was launched in 2015 it
takes advantage of our scanning
technology to look at applications that
are published to Google Play and find
potential security issues not bad
behavior by the application but just a
mistake including an old version of a
library that's no longer up to date miss
handling a particular type of
certificate when managing encryption on
an HTTPS connection so in 2016 we
expanded the scope of that program
adding over 18 new checks for potential
security issues and helping developers
know about the flaws that were
introduced into their applications and
correct them in 2017 we're going to
continue to do that we think this is
really
sort of foundational technology that's
unique to Android but shows how we're
very committed to openness into helping
developers flourish on the platform so
that openness is a double-edged sword
one of the things that comes of being
open and transparent and encouraging
security research on the platform is
news and sometimes that news can be a
little bit biting and so one of the
things that we want to do is take a look
back at some of the larger stories in
talk about what's happened and make sure
that people recognize how much
protections have been put in place in
direct response to some of these issues
so the first example of a potentially
harmful application that received
significant attention in 2016 was named
Turkish clicker by checkpoint and
research that they published this year
this was actually a family that Google
had been tracking through both Google
Play and outside of Google Play since
2014 so it's one that we've been
monitoring for quite a while
what was interesting about it is it a
diversified significantly around the
world and had a large number of
different applications that had been
built so it was very actively at trying
to evade detection both by Google and by
others in the security research
community by the end of 2016 the
protections that we had built as well as
some of the ones that were made
available by other third parties had
done a great job and basically by the
end of 2016
we'd seen Turkish clicker come to an
almost complete decline ghost push was
the name of a family that received
significant attention in the middle of
2015 and actually it was quite prominent
in our 2015 year in review as well at
one point in 2015 it represented almost
half of the overall installs that were
taking place in the ecosystem was so
aggressive and across the entire year
ghost Bush was about a third of the
overall potential harmful applications
that were installed in the Android
ecosystem in 2015 this graph and the
discussion that's inside the year in
review talks about the protections that
were put in place and the fact that by
the end of 2016 we basically aren't
seeing ghost push at all anymore their
efforts to install applications have
been thwarted through a combination of
direct intervention by Google as well as
intervention
in partnership with our OEM partners and
some of the others in the Android
ecosystem in order to protect the
installation of these applications onto
devices
another example that received fairly
large attention was a family called
humming bad these applications routed
the device and then tried to take
advantage of third-party properties on
the web and that's a common theme that
you might have seen across the last
three families where they're really
trying to monetize the devices through
abuse such as installing applications or
going after properties on the web what
we didn't see a lot of in 2016 were
applications that tried to actually
access user data usually if there was
any access of user data it was to get at
credentials to facilitate installation
of applications or another sort of
commercial mechanism but the short of it
is for humming bad identified over
24,000 unique applications a large
number of install attempts around the
world but almost all of them are outside
of Google Play and so here was a an area
where the protections in Google Play
were sufficient to prevent all but one
instance of the application in the
humming bed family getting on to Google
Play and so most of the activity was
outside of Google Play the cleanup was
successful and at this point we're
seeing very few installations of humming
baton to undo user devices and so to
summarize when we're looking at
potentially harmful applications what
we've seen consistently is early
detection by Google Play or by the
Google efforts to identify potentially
harmful applications researchers in the
security community flagging or
identifying these things and generating
headlines and media interest in them a
little bit later in 2016 but that
ultimately soon after that we see those
families begin to recede in terms of
their effectiveness
and the impact that they have on users
so the last thing that we wanted to
mention was I've hinted at it a few
times the goal here was to summarize
some of the highlights from our annual
report there's a link should be
somewhere behind me I think to describe
where you can go to grab the annual Year
in Review I would encourage you to read
it it gets into a lot more detail on
individual families on individual
actions that have been introduced and
gives you a good sense for where it is
that we see Android security going in
2016 and a precursor to where it'll be
going into the future so thank you very
much I appreciate you taking the time
and have a good rest of your day